luxury to me in luxury today and and I
think in the future is not to do with
materiality as much as the spatial and
environmental qualities of living in
other words luxury doesn't require gold
taps and marble floors luxury is about
space and environmental comfort in
today's increasingly dense and chaotic
world original surface a warehouse the
whole area alongside the Singapore River
was a go down area so Martin number 38
replaces and all go down well we elected
first of all to retain a dual side that
had natural vegetation on it the next
thing we did was to hoist the building
up to its maximum height limit of 15
floors of course captures the view it
maximizes the potential for breeze and
it created a series of volumes beneath
the tower that were given over to open
space in the form of pool decks and
pockets of garden there's really only
two architectural elements major
elements or major moves one is the tower
which has the apartment accommodation
and the other is the publicly accessible
areas which are design within a two
story block at the ground level so
eighty percent of our building is
apartments and the balance consists of
restaurant the cafe fact it's a Thai
restaurant and the food's pretty good
and the gymnasium which is also for
health club which is also open to the
public the response to climate has been
a very important aspect for a design it
was planned to maximize natural cross
ventilation you know in in the tropics
we actually have a lot of gloomy days
overcast and gloomy days so the trick is
not to exclude the Sun but to invite it
in through system of filters it created
tall lofty naturally ventilated lift
lobbies and this reduces energy
consumption and they've also provided a
great transparency between the the
vegetation on the small hill that we
protective and the public areas and
communal areas of the development I
think it sits comfortably within the
surroundings it is not too demonstrative
I think its proportions sit quietly
within the surrounding landscape perhaps
it's for others to judge
you